welcome to this first video for the
Chess Olympiad 2012 in Istanbul and
discovers the first round I try to make
a daily video form for each round and
present some some highlights of this
round first round of course them so lots
of very uneven matches where the top
teams repaired again against a very much
lower rated opponent so it's pretty much
yeah must-win situation for all the
bigger teams and if i'm not mistaken on
all favorites one that matches there
hasn't been an upset in match terms but
there have been quite some single game
upsets were very much lower rated
players managed to win or draw their
games in terms of wins there have been
some notable defeats like young Luke
from really lost lost his game against a
field master and um I think email to
Trotsky also lost with white even so
there have been a couple of upsets but I
depict two games that are liked and
they're interesting to watch the first
one here is from the metra Bolivian
versus some amenia amenia being one of
the the top favorites for the title they
already won the chess olympiad in two
thousand six and two thousand eight and
here in the first round against bolivia
they played without them aboard one of
course Levon Aronian they played this
first round with Moses on aslam first
board here playing black against him the
Bolivian Grandmaster osvaldo's Zambrano
never heard of him but he did a very
good job in this game so let's see and
what happens um okay I need to do this
first and now we have the first move
before
please take note that the clock times
are bogus and I just imported this game
here to the software so ignore the clock
times it was a classical tournament game
and also one word about the possible not
so great the video quality I'm doing
this in my vacation from a notebook so I
simply don't have the screen estate to
to do it to do it in very high quality
so on ok he fought was played and hast
AZ on play since the Sicilian this is
what he usually does and we got an open
Sicilian and a time on offer variation
my transposed to some other lines but
it's initially the time on off this is
has been a favorite of most asians for
years so nothing special no surprise you
play played a six-year this is so an
interesting point here like has mostly
to moose it's a six has played or quincy
seven which also fits into the terminal
scheme but queens is heavy and nam
comparison as a slight disadvantage that
in case of an English attack formation
like this year it's not so clear that
the Queen own oops that the Queen wants
to be on c7 this is simply in some cases
not the ideal scram it's of course
playable for black but what he did here
the a6 moose is designed to bring white
to get away from this this English a
texture that we can see why and the game
why just played them you should be three
Knight f6 and now F form if he at this
point would try to go towards them the
English attack with f3 then the queen is
back on d 8 and black can very quickly
play stuff like Bishop before
and then g5 and quickly attack you form
this is um this is very useful and you
don't really need the Queen on since
having to do that so it's basically one
move up with this counter play this is
why why term tries to go with f4 here
nowadays we should be formed to tech
before porn and of course white just
covers it and now if five this is an
interesting move of course I don't know
I'm really the theory of this I had to
look it up to get some idea this has
been played before but to be honest it
leads to a position type that i would
say famous white but okay i'm not an
expert let's see what happens why took
on c6 like we captured with the decon
and now a five and if white would would
take here then this kind of news is
irritating also possibly 94 is possible
maybe even ID form but then this this
move is irritating enough to do with
would get back d 5 and then have a good
square on five so on but this is not the
idea nor white played f5 and this is the
kind of position that I'm um yeah of
what I just said that I don't like it
very much White has an automatic idea
here to advance further on the thin side
gain space and black doesn't have so
clear counter play especially in the
bishop 1c8 is in the way peace it just
bites on this f5 porn and gala black
would need to do is to to put at some
point B 5 there should be seven and even
then it's no pressure against before I
don't like it so much maybe it is ok but
it's not a position that that I would
like to play him of ZZ and played h5 and
I think this must be a prepared move
because um obviously you did some
prep for this game and I looked in the
database that was actually one game of
this wide players and Branagh yet this
on the board perform about 45 years ago
where his opponent took only form an
interesting tactical move relying on the
fact that black has got this Queen age
for check to get get the piece back so
let's say here this kind of idea and you
get it back with the huge advantage
probably so taking only force is bad but
White's ideas Quincy form and this is
quite an interesting way to play what
grabs the bishop like retreats and
queenie form and after some complication
this led to an end game where white was
initially porn down but voted back
quickly and had a good position
especially i'm considering that
movsisyan suddenly wanted to to get some
winning chances in this game he's after
all about 200 something points higher
rated maybe he rejected this on this
grounds so this is why he went went with
h5 but still I don't really like the
position so and I doubt them a bit in
the kind of preparation here I think
it's quite comfortable for wild yeah he
went Queen f3 logical move to probably
prepare long castles and Nyjah for
trying to sludge this not disturb Bishop
it moved away and then Bishop c5 this
was the idea to get them this at the end
to play but white can simply attack this
he am plate the plate and Bishop Knight
you have to and now look f1 and all this
here I'm not sure about from blacks
point of view because now you have
before so protected from with the spawn
and it's not so easy to see how black
would attack the d3 porn and white still
has the space advantage I rather like
YTM
he played this to provoke the g3 move
and then drop back and then I think that
not much of a difference of course black
gum just a short quickly couldn't take
here after this you don't have a place
for the Queen ok so let them go back
here he went to be seven and now watch
just classic long trip in rugby five as
mentioned there's no other place for the
bishop really maybe you could have
played a move like Bishop d7 that it's
all very pensive to agree a king be one
was a good move to prepare this one f6
rook c1 and now White has some ideas
against the pawn on d6 and also we can
maybe try to get a piece to c5 if you
would be able to establish a piece on c5
then black is really AM vehicles to
being dead with the bishop that will
never get anything in the game so you
should be seven you should be three wide
would like to exchange the bishops and
he retreated in fact I quickly looked at
at this smooth and c5 to free this
Bishop a bit it's biting a bit on
granite but still it may be a
possibility to play like this c5 looks
very weak though but maybe it son that's
an alternative the little direct and 95
I'm not so sure about if this is really
a promising continuation as black has
got this at the energy five point isn't
especially strong so maybe it was an
idea to take on e3 we really need to
look for improvements because pretty
soon black gets into a very problematic
position yeah bishop back to d6 and now
g-form and he took it and now in a bit
surprisingly for me at least
[ __ ] with the Queen it's not bad not bad
at all I mean if you take with the pawn
I'm h2 h3 takes you four wide certainly
would have been better also but this is
some very direct move also putting
pressure on g7 not not bad at all and
now along castles maybe this is this is
a mistake maybe it's easy to tell after
the game maybe Bishop c7 was an
alternative to prepare long Castle spam
button because white now has this very
direct mighty n95 queen here and now we
should be six and thumb yeah this looks
looks really uncomfortable he went Luke
t7 it was attacked after all and now the
very nice move Queen to g1 this is
really a high-class move the idea is to
transfer the Queen to the queenside
prepare move like Bishop to c5 maybe I'm
very very good move and yeah what should
leg do now p.m. he grabbed this pawn if
he doesn't do this then Bishop c5 really
as a problem let's say some random move
Queen here then this is in this is Sam
yeah almost dead for black he needs to
take here and then you have this coming
up and like we'll use on c 6-r or a 6
and a good King this terrible so I think
relatively best was to take watch what
he did um yeah here white played it in a
very straightforward manner he could
have made some some less forcing move
also keep some advantage but he just
sucked the rook spectacularly on c6 very
nice move the ideas okay black needs to
take no no discussion rook c1 and yeah
what should black do now
the bishop is hanging and not much that
you can do let's say he goes um king
here then Bishop f5 with this idea it's
just deadly this is the nice point of
this Queen g1 move that the queen is so
quickly joining the attack a black has
no defense here he would take here then
it's just made coming up with whoopsie
aid so it's it's lost he cannot protect
the bishop and he needs to play some
news obviously and what what should like
do um in the game he went for the smooth
possibly intending some counter play I'm
an alternative and the very decent
alternative probably was to take him and
after this at least in my analysis which
wasn't like five hours long I didn't
find a win funny enough it looked super
dangerous maybe one of you guys with
lots of time on your hands find one when
I don't identified one can we send
ambition a five and it looks it looks
terrible with them with queen bee six
but luck has this this blocking move
route before and I don't see how wide
can crash through here I simply don't
see it and something like this here is
probably a draw with this intention and
now back and we can do this for hours I
didn't find it one maybe you found one
it seems to me that Luke text III would
have would have saved the game so maybe
from a theoretical point of view this
group's e6 sacrifice wasn't the best
move but it put ya noms pressure on like
auntie he really cracked down now and
played this Queen age five and this is
winning now for
he took c6 was check and ya like like a
has to block this he simply cannot move
the King again he goes here you have
have this very nice move oops the Queen
og one is just brilliant attacking this
pawn and this Queen B 6 idea this is
made next smooth oh ok Queen a 787 and
so on the black is mated on C 7i 0 7
some black needs to interpose what she
did and sorry what she did and now maybe
why didn't play the most exact move
probably but it's it's difficult he
played the Quincy one if if white would
have played Bishop takes e7 here I
things he would have won much quicker
but it's not it's not so trivial takes
and then of course there's Luke edge one
but in fact why can just take and go for
this and after let's say queen here you
should retreat Queen takes here what
should be a completely winning with look
c7 to come this is this is a mating
neither almost i think it's a it's it's
dead lost I had the computers on + 7 or
something it's so it should be winning
but I guess white maybe miscalculated
something here but it needs to be said
that what he played probably is winning
as well or not saying it's not winning
but damn it's um it's the puts lots of
problems some on the board for black he
played this Quincy one attacking c7 even
more
look here the only move otherwise you
don't simply lose immediately and now we
should Bishop g1 and here black actually
can take and this is the the big point
here what needs to recap and take off
take a course first here and now it's of
course you cannot check made because of
the rook he needs to grab the rook first
and of course this position still looks
a very promising for why the black has
got some counter play with Queenie too
it all depends on what happens in the
game because this is completely forced
queen here takes and Quincy for this was
all forced and it leads to an end game
which we got in the game well why does a
porn down but if you look at this a bit
closer you will see that why does some
the absolute only player here and who
can play for win because the sea for
porn is common Utley week what permanent
this may be the wrong word it will
probably get lost in the near future and
then you have a dominating night where
this bad Bishop end game after all blogs
extra porn is g7 and this is not worth
much at the moment so it really depends
on this end game um white um activated
some his King and black knob played
Kingi seven anthem at this point I think
maybe you should have tried this one
King v7 the idea being King here and
should be six I think this would have
been much better the ideas with white
goes here you can play this move oops
and grab him and this is much better
than than the game and I'm not sure it
probably still critical for black
because this pawn is simply not worth
nothing and white can try to still in
weight but him him
I think he needed to do this in the game
it was some it was pretty come on the
game in bikini 7 it was pretty easy in
comparison for why to win king see to
Bishop Guth and now just 93 attacking
the porn and black him has no way to to
save it simply that King here white grab
this and now we have a position with
equal material but white will get the
dominating night until of course has two
against one so possible um passed pawn
quickly while black hair still has
problems to use his pawn this is just
lost now and some Branagh um does a good
technical job I think yeah now transfer
the night to to f5 just to make sure
these pawns don't move you have time
don't need to rush things now a for King
f4 and the transfer back to d5 black has
absolutely no counter play and now the
very neat move a five and this is really
they are very aesthetic finish to the
game this night controls the the squares
and white simply threatens be five and a
six so we see here F 5v5 it took and
here in this position after eight X be
five a six and yeah and what white is
winning um actually maybe I accidentally
edit one or two move see in my file I
think I most lazy and resigned one or
two moose earlier so a very very nice
game by the Bolivian Grandmaster here
who really am put lots of pressure on
North Asian who maybe had chances to to
save the game but he was really under
pressure throughout and didn't manage to
to cope with that um in general in terms
of the match amenia won they won the
other three games
so pretty yeah in a pretty convincing
fashion so it wasn't a disaster in terms
of the measure sending all right and
this was the first game I want to show a
second one let me just load this here
oops okay this wasn't intended all right
so this is some again which I won't show
um so um so deeply just a second here
need to to fix something okay I'm ready
so at the second game was from the match
of the the German team they played a new
zealand in the first round and um one
pretty convincingly three and a half
what does a half and this game was the
most interesting one I guess played on
board tube between feet and macerated I
think 2215 around this against the ego
Chang Caine used about 26 50 60 or
something about 400 points higher okay
so let's see it was a sharp battle
default played d5 c4 and check into GaN
see for now i have three and now the
rare move but interesting move c6 and
the Queens gambit accepted usually black
plays some instead of this place on this
night f6 moved the most popular one but
this often leads to somewhat less
interesting positions I'm just just to
give an example like always needs to
reckon with this kind of line which is
pretty much the worst kind of opening
you can play against someone lower rated
than you to win to win at least to draw
is ok but to
it's very difficult with black ass white
easily can exchanging more pieces and
has no weaknesses so of course check in
didn't want to do something like this he
played this his six month which is much
more complicated the ideas we see it
immediately III and now he played b5
covering this pawn white um of course
them with a somewhat slow move like III
he needs to get it back he cannot play
this in gambit style and occupy the
center you must try to get the pawn back
so am attacked the pawn chain with a 4 u
6 plate and now takes takes be three so
we see that black am probably won't be
able to hold the sixth upon but he's got
other ideas he played Bishop before
check Bishop t2 needs to do that you
cannot play something like this and like
immediately wins so Bishop t2 was the
only move takes Knight takes and now a
five it's a very very sharp set up that
like chose iam he doesn't develop any
peace but he installs these very
dangerous pawns which in the long run
can win the game just by advancing and
queening so it's a very sharp position
it through very much resembles the
notable variation of the semi Slav and
the difference being that in the Notre
bone-white would have a bishop on b2
which it doesn't have here it's a very
similar in structure though and very
sharp kind of position where you can
easily play for a win with black but you
can also easily lose the game it's very
risky okay wide place a 95 a good move
immediately threatening to take here
because there are some news pieces black
hasn't developed anything the only made
the pawn moves beside this Bishop
exchange okay black needs to catch up
and development
we should be three in general it is also
an idea for wide to play c5 early in
this some kind of positions I don't want
to make a big theoretical server here
just focus on the main point in this
game so they are both continued with
pretty logical looking moves also f4
supports the night end intense further
actions on the kingside night here
Bishop c2 also a good idea blocking the
pawns h6 look not so sure but this is
really necessary okay Queenie one
attending Queen shifts to the Kings side
took on d5 retreated and here white
played 90 for this I think a mistake um
maybe you should have played them
something like this after all the
problem with 94 is not dead oops but
this was too quick add this also I'm
sorry need to get back to the game
position the problem with 94 is not that
this would be a bad idea the problem is
the technical one like now could play b3
using the fact that white cannot capture
because this thing is saying so what was
forced to play the bishop and now a
foreign this really helped like
tremendously the strands of the pawns on
Gavin it's always a very dramatic kind
of position type where any kind of slope
labour white relief litres defeat and
after he allowed this pause to get it
once he really needs to get going
quickly and he does so first the night
gets to its active post like moves the
bishop and now white goes for this this
this battery type of a check on h7
Queen a five I think a good move 23 hmm
with very direct ideas f5 black needed
to do that yeah white captured keeping
the diagonal open and black recaptured
with the night yeah and now we have a
kind of position where it's a really
yeah a do or die kind of situation if
white um doesn't play something very
direct very brutal quickly these pawns
will simply promote to Queens so we
decided which is not the best move maybe
in a mathematical sense but from
practical point of view this is just
right he decided to to simply take the
snide and crash through to age seven in
this position I'm drinking recaptured
which is perfectly okay he had an end
alternative though they could have
played actually this move the idea
somewhere white doesn't have so much
choice he needs to retreat here rook
takes Queen takes Queen takes here and
now go into deform and I think black is
just winning in this position but okay
you need to see this still and he didn't
obviously i did some miscalculation it's
not completely easy to do this um he
took on f6 we just mentioned isn't a
mistake but it suddenly am demands much
more position from you what gives his
check King evade only move check came
here and Queen caption on g7 you see
like really needs to be a tough year
with the skin the King needs to walk
right into the center now and in fact a
firm if you believe the the the engine
here and black is winning but it takes
some strong nerves to play this dev c5
check and King to d5 is right in the
middle of the board in the other line
legs
he would have been perfectly safe and
this is why this is preferable really
also from practical point of view yeah
white here did Ruby the best he could do
he gave this check drawn the King even
further into white scam he knew to take
i infected sorry sorry I'm sorry he
could have he actually could have played
kings ii form but office hits it's very
very hard to do this I don't have the
exact times of this game I'm not sure if
they are available even somewhere
because it was played on the much lower
boards um would be interesting to know
about campaigns time situation I play
sometimes played together with him and
the Belgium leak is in the same Club um
he doesn't play every match but
sometimes he does play and he tends to
get into absolutely weird time travel
sometimes it's possible that he didn't
have much on the clock very much
possible well what you did is perfectly
okay taking was ok it's so winning but
and the mistakes them is one was the
mistake is coming coming a bit later
Queen f6 and here black could win but
not easy at all he could have played
here Queen d2 and I think this is
winning intending to grab the porn also
with the Queen so possible line would be
this and wide can take here but this
should be willing it's it's not easy at
all if you don't have lots of time on
the clock you can easily one go astray
here and in the game has managed he
didn't you didn't play this steal this
Queen d2 you played the king here yeah
and now in fact it's a draw white plate
Queen f1 check and how would like escape
now if he goes back then you
losing with rook team on and you cannot
prevent these mates I'm not sure maybe
overlook this I'm not sure and so what
should like do in the game he went here
where else and then it's it's just
checks like simply cannot escape snow
there's no way so after a couple of more
checks the draw was agreed I think
exactly I think here here the drag games
on here the draw was agreed so I think
what really did all he could in this
position after he slightly went astray
with along with sp3 stuff here in this
position allowing me three after this he
really did a good job grabbing f6 and
try and really do to to muddy the waters
and black made those one or two
inaccuracies that cost him the victory
in this game but it's very
understandable I I for instance always
tend to play very badly if the king is
running around the board and there's
lots of checks if we didn't have much
time it wasn't was it easy at all so
nice King hunt here leading to draw you
don't see this too often the King on d5
would Queens on the board but I hope you
enjoyed the two games i'll be doing a
further coverage of round two and
probably i'll upload do the videos in
the day the day after each round
sometimes maybe in the evening but it's
the holidays and need to relax a bit at
times and it not can do videos all the
time yeah thanks for watching